En un video anterior exploramos la distribución
muestral que obtuvimos cuando tomamos la
diferencia entre las proporciones muestrales.
Ahí describimos la distribución en términos
de su media, desviación estándar y forma. Lo
que vamos a hacer en este video es tomar este
ejemplo para tratar de averiguar más cosas al
respecto. Entonces, en esta situación lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar la probabilidad
dado lo que ya sabemos acerca de la forma,
desviación estándar y media de esta distribución
muestral. Nos dicen: "Encuentra la probabilidad de
que la proporción muestral de autos defectuosos de
la Planta B sea mayor que la proporción muestral
de la Planta A". Así que pausa este video y ve
si puedes resolverlo. Muy bien, ahora hagamos
esto juntos. En primer lugar, interpretemos esto:
la probabilidad de que la proporción muestral de
autos defectuosos de la Planta B sea mayor que la
proporción muestral de la Planta A. Entonces, si
la proporción muestral de la Planta B es mayor que
la proporción muestral de la Planta A, entonces la
diferencia entre las proporciones muestrales
será negativa, esto es equivalente a la
probabilidad de que la diferencia entre las
proporciones muestrales, es decir, P(PA - PB)
˂ 0. Gráficamente esto corresponde a esta área de
aquí. Ahora, hay muchas formas en las que podemos
calcular esta área, pero la más fácil, o una de
las más fáciles -imagino que hay muchas otras
formas diferentes de hacerlo- es averiguar, bueno,
cuántas desviaciones estándar hay por debajo de la
media, incluyendo esta, y luego podemos usar una
tabla zeta. Así que lo que tenemos que hacer es
averiguar cuál es el valor z aquí, y el valor z
aquí ¿a cuántas desviaciones estándar por debajo
de la media equivale? Y lo haré aquí arriba,
permíteme despejar esto, z va a ser igual a,
estamos a -0.02 de la media o 0.02 a la izquierda
de la media, así que es -0.02, y luego, sobre la
desviación estándar, que es 0.025, lo que será
igual a, uso la calculadora aquí: 0.02 dividido
entre 0.025 es igual a eso, y, por supuesto,
vamos a estar a la izquierda de la media, entonces
nuestra zeta será aproximadamente -0.8, y digo
aproximadamente porque el valor que calculamos
aquí de la desviación estándar fue aproximado,
entonces es -0.8. Y luego sólo tenemos que buscar
esto en una tabla zeta, entonces si miramos una
tabla de valores z, vemos que si ubicamos a -0.8,
que está justo aquí, y luego tenemos ceros
después de eso -por lo que nos encontramos aquí-,
el área bajo la curva normal hasta ese valor z,
inclusive, es -recuerda que debes asegurarte de
que estamos viendo el valor correcto en esta tabla
de probabilidades normales estándar de aquí-,
esto nos da 0.21, o podríamos decir que es
aproximadamente un 21%, así que permíteme
deshacerme de esto. Y entonces sabemos que esto
de aquí es aproximadamente el 21%, o podríamos
decir 0.21, por lo que la probabilidad de que
la proporción muestral de autos defectuosos de
la Planta B sea mayor que la proporción muestral
de la Planta A es aproximadamente 1 de cada 5.